the end of the world is officially upon
us because now precisely five years and
one day ago Saint Greta of the Blessed
sailboat Miss thundberg herself
predicted it she tweeted
in a curiously deleted tweet that quote
a Top Class A top climate scientist how
dare you she said a top climate
scientist is warning that climate change
will wipe out all of humanity unless we
stop using fossil fuels over the next
five years now to be fair to Greta she
did not say that the world would end in
five years
she said that climate change would wipe
out all of humanity unless we stop using
fossil fuels over the next five years
and those are different claims
but the Practical consequence of them
is pretty similar pretty much the same
whether we're already dead
or merely inevitably doomed there is now
according to Greta Thornburg absolutely
no reason to try to do anything about
so-called climate change it's too late
we could all stop driving our cars and
cooking our food and heating our homes
and fueling our societies today we could
we could turn off the whole thing
which would coincidentally wipe out all
of humanity just by doing that but we
could do it let's say we did it still
it would be too late
climate change activism is now
officially pointless so eat drink heat
Drive burn up those fossil fuels and be
merry I'm Michael nolsas the Michael
Knowles show
thank you
[Music]
welcome back
show wonderful wonderful to be back uh
great news coming out of Twitter and
Elon Musk
Elon has said that the word sis this is
c-i-s
will now be banned as as hate speech you
know it's if people are spamming the
word CIS at normal people then it will
be banned as and I think this is great
some libertarian types are upset about
this but this is awesome we'll get to
that in a second speaking of Twitter I
had to open with Greta today because
these guys
the catastrophizing libs always make
predictions that are just far enough in
the future that nobody really calls them
out on it nobody really remembers when
the time comes and so they get away with
it and they then the predictions never
come true and then they make more
catastrophic predictions if you don't do
exactly what I say or The Whole World's
Gonna end in like seven years or
whatever and then seven years come by
people forget about it but Twitter makes
it
much easier to refer back to those
predictions and just remember
it it's either totally wrong
in which case there's no reason to
believe Saint Greta and the rest of the
environmentalist types or it's too late
or Greta was right and it's just too
late and nothing we do now can possibly
save us all of humanity will be wiped
out but either way
if we are to take Greta dunberg at her
word
it's over it's over that's a that's a
cause for celebration we're not wiped
out yet but we don't need to worry now
about driving a stupid Prius or
something we're good we're good guys
speaking of predictions being wrong
there's a little oopsie Daisy just came
out of the Pentagon this will affect you
it will affect your pocketbook a little
bit of an accounting error over at the
Department of Defense
accidentally might have provided over 6
billion extra dollars for Ukraine oops
during the Department's regular
oversight of our execution of
presidential drawdown Authority for
Ukraine we discovered inconsistencies in
equipment valuation for Ukraine in a
significant number of cases Services
used replacement costs rather than net
Book value thereby overestimating the
value of the equipment drawn down from
U.S stocks and provided to Ukraine once
we discovered this misvaluation the
Comptroller reissued guidance on March
31st clarifying how to Value equipment
in line
with the financial management regulation
and DOD policy to ensure we use the most
accurate of accounting methods we have
confirmed that for FY 23 the final
calculation is 3.6 billion dollars and
for FY 22 it is 2.6 billion for a
combined total of 6.2 billion dollars
these valuation errors in no way limit
or restricted the size of any of our
pdas or impacted the provision of
support to Ukraine
just want to use this as an example of
why I frequently say that I don't ever
trust statistics it's all bunk money is
fungible and manipulable especially when
you've got strong central governments
and you've got cozy relationships with
banks and it's easy
to move all this stuff around especially
when you've got an administrative State
that's not really accountable to the
people that just does whatever it wants
do you see what she did here
it's not that the Biden Administration
is saying oh whoops we misplaced six
billion dollars the government has done
that sort of thing before but it's not
they say oh you know you know how you
lose your car keys well yeah we lost six
billion dollars and now we found out
we're gonna give it back to Ukraine
that's not what happened here
the U.S said
okay we're gonna give a bunch of
Military Support to Ukraine because
we're fighting a war with Russia now
it's a proxy war in Ukraine the American
people don't really want it I don't
think but they're going to do it anyway
doesn't matter who gets elected they're
probably just going to keep fighting
this war one way or another and
they say okay we're sending over these
arms we're sending over these Munitions
all right here we go we've given
gazillions of dollars to Ukraine
you the Ukraine was unpopular
politically right now but the U.S still
wants to fund the war because the U.S is
if not the chief belligerent in the war
we're the biggest one by far and Russia
is referring to the Ukraine war as a
direct hot conflict with the United
States we managed to avoid that for all
of the Cold War but now somehow we're
doing it over a territorial dispute
that's gone on for a thousand years in
Eastern Europe so
now the the U.S government wants to keep
fighting this war it's politically
unpopular so what do they do they say oh
we didn't actually give all the money
that we said we gave
and how can they make that claim well
the way they can make that claim is by
revising down the estimates of value of
the of all of the military equipment
that we've sent over
but that's the way to free up the money
if you say okay well look I sent you I
sent you a hundred dollars
I sent you a thousand dollars in the
form of
nice bottles of whiskey
okay I I got I got you a hundred dollar
bottle of whiskey and I bought you 10 of
them and I sent there you go there's a
thousand dollars in Aid but let's say I
want to send you some more whiskey
well the way to do that
is not just if you can't find the money
in the couch you're going to say oh
actually that bottle of whiskey there
was a hundred dollars no I got that
number wrong that bottle of whiskey that
was actually only worth 20 bucks yeah so
really I only sent you like 200 worth of
whiskey so I'm gonna send you 800 more
whiskey nothing changed you've sent all
the same stuff we all know what's going
on it's just you're finding an excuse to
send more support over without having to
technically or so transparently disturb
what you've already agreed to do and
what the American people are already
counting on now you know one great
company that does not fuss around on the
price or on the product that would be
cinch right now go to cinch.com use
promo code Knowles picture picture it
the perfect Summer Night the warm breeze
just gently lapping your face as you
Lounge in your favorite chair outside
the grill sizzling with Juicy gooey
Burgers the aroma of the food it's
irresistible boy I need a hot shower
after this or a cold shower I guess well
now imagine
what this perfect summer night would
look like if you went to turn on the
grill and your propane tank or empty
that's where our friends at cinch come
in cinch is a propane grill tank Home
Delivery Service they deliver propane
grill tanks right to your door since
delivers on your schedule and requires
no long-term commitment or a
subscription plus delivery is completely
contactless you don't have to wait
around at home track the order on the
Cinch app from anywhere whether you're
grilling steaks or lighting up the patio
heaters on a cold night cinches propane
delivery service ensures that you have
the fuel you need to make the most of
every moment
go to cinch.com or download the synch
app to order new customers can get their
first tank exchanges for just 10 bucks
with promo code Knolls that's cinch.com
or download the Cinch app use promo code
nulls to get your first tank exchange
for just ten dollars this is a limited
time offer you must live with an
essential service area to redeem it go
to cinch.com offer for details also just
to get back to the global warming thing
for a second
all those tanks and fighter jets and
they're probably burning some fossil
fuels in Ukraine right it's kind of
interesting all those really Pro
environmentalist anti-global warming
activists they seem to be fine burning
up the they they're fine burning up
fossil fuels for certain purposes
like fighting an imperial war in Ukraine
but not for other purposes like poor
people heating their homes or senior
citizens on fixed incomes having a stove
that you're not you're not allowed to do
that speaking of heavy equipment
probably the biggest
unexpected news story that is taking
people's attention right now really
awful awful story there is a submersible
it's not quite a summary exactly it's a
submersible
device that is carrying five people
somewhere in deep sea in the middle of
the Atlantic Ocean they were on a trip
to go look at the Titanic and the
company lost contact with the
submersible pretty quickly and now
they're running out of air or the US
government's involved trying to recover
this but you know they're looking at a
search area the size of the state of
Connecticut and the submersible is not
very big it's pretty cramped and so it's
it's just about as horrifying a story as
one could imagine in terms of ways to go
just in a cramped little Tin Can at the
bottom of the Atlantic ocean near the
Titanic that's pretty terrifying where
you don't know
we don't really know what's happened to
these people there's a chance they're
already dead and the way they would have
died is uh if the somehow the cabin
became depressurized and then the weight
of the ocean would have just crushed it
all up that would have been very quick
or they could just be waiting somewhere
with waiting for the oxygen to run out
which apparently is going to happen or
may have already happened by 5 a.m
eastern time
um
or
it might take months and months to find
this submersible or we might never find
this immersible uh
people are criticizing the company right
now because the company seems to have
cut some corners on safety and seems to
have gone a little bit woke and said
they wouldn't hire old white guys
because that's not inspiring enough or
something here's here's some audio of
the head of the company
when I started the business one of the
things you'll find there are other
sub-operators out there but they they
typically
um have a gentlemen who are ex-military
submariners and they you'll see a whole
bunch of 50 year old white guys I wanted
our team to be younger to be
inspirational and I'm not going to
inspire a 16 year old to go pursue
Marine technology but a 25 year old uh
you know who's a subpilot or a platform
operator or one of our techs can be
inspirational so we've really tried to
to get
um very intelligent motivated younger
individuals involved because we're doing
things that are completely new we're
taking approaches that are used largely
in the Aerospace industry is related to
safety and uh some of the profounders of
checklists things we do for risk
assessments and things like that that
are more Aviation related than ocean
related and we can train people to do
that we can train someone to Pilot this
up we use a game controller um so
anybody can drive the sub
so they use a game controller they've
used all this new kind of Technology
they've applied aviation technology to
the sub the critics are saying you cut
too many corners this was insane why on
Earth would anyone get into this thing
uh The Defenders of this are saying well
this is the Explorer spirit this is
Adventure this is a great we shouldn't
discourage this of course you got to be
a little bit crazy to go explore parts
of the world and that's a good thing and
we should encourage it
the people knew the risks that that
seems to be certain there's a 61 year
old British digital marketing magnet
named Chris Brown he had put a deposit
down to go on on a voyage on this
submersible and then he backed out at
the last minute because he said the
risks are too high he said the risks
were too high in this instance even
though I'm not one to shy away from risk
and he was buddies with a billionaire
Hamish Harding who is down there in the
submersible and Harding said okay well
I'm willing to accept the risk
there's a teenager also with his father
that's especially sad but but people at
least knew this was a risky thing and
they decided to do it anyway
I am not on either side of the internet
debate over the
wisdom or idiocy of getting in this sub
Mar defending the adventure Spirit some
are criticizing the recklessness I think
that Prudence is called for here
I don't think that the proper response
to this is either condemnation or
valorization of what they're doing I
think the prop and some people are
making jokes about it and posting memes
and it's really sad I mean these are
human beings who are either dead or
could very soon die
I think the proper response is prayer
for the people and also prayer for the
wisdom to make these kinds of judgments
I am not of the opinion that it's always
a great and wonderful thing to go climb
Mount Everest
I don't I don't think that's true I
think sometimes it can be Reckless and
suicidal and deeply dark
and sinister
and I'm also not of the opinion that
it's always a terrible thing to go climb
Mount Everest
that you should just stay in your home
and always make the safe Choice I'm not
of that opinion either
it's a little bit more complicated
you've got to use your prudence and your
judgment and and calculate risks and
weigh risks and see what's to be gained
here some of the people criticizing uh
this company or saying well this you
weren't exploring anything new you were
just going down to a shipwreck that's
one of the most studied shipwrecks ever
so this was just tourism and it was
tourism that cut a lot of corners and
was very very expensive but I don't know
on the other hand as far as tourism goes
it's pretty pretty adventurous it seems
to me and and so I just think when we
make these decisions on on all political
matters
we are especially in the digital age
where we're addicted to extremism and
clicks we we just want to be able to say
okay here is the solution it's always
good to go do the extremely dangerous
thing or no this is never good this is
dumb and this is stupid we should mock
these people and I know a lot more about
submarines than this company desert but
that isn't the case you see it on speech
say we need absolute Free Speech or some
people say no we need to strongly censor
the conservatives what if
what if there is a moderate middle
ground that takes into account
all of these kinds of ideas and then
exercises Prudence moderation is a
virtue I consider myself very moderate I
know the libs think that I'm to the
right of Genghis Khan but I can say I'm
a very moderate person you know now
speaking of imprudence Bud Light baby
Bud Light is getting absolutely wrecked
still Bud Light sales
it's not just that they dropped in the
week after transheiser Bush decided to
endorse a drag queen
or a transvestite or whatever whatever
Dylan wolf and he calls himself it's
it's not just that they dropped and then
they went back up it's not even just
that they dropped and they stayed where
they were they dropped and then they
kept dropping and then they kept
dropping and it looked like they kind of
had cratered but no they kept dropping
they've crept they've kept dropping
again sales revenue plunge 26.8 percent
in the week ending June 10th according
to new data that is a new low
for weekly sales revenue the previous
highest weekly drop for Bud Light was
25.7 percent
and now 26.8 so what is Bud Light doing
what is transheiser Bush doing first of
all I think that company owes Alyssa
hershenfeld or whatever that VP of
marketing was they owe her an apology
because she took the fall for this but
this is obviously a conscious decision
by transheiser Bush made it a much
higher level than the VP of marketing so
why are they doing it
why would Bud Light consistently
irritate the customers and not just
apologize
because
Bud Light has to keep up it's ESG score
trans-hiser Bush ESG the environmental
social governance policies which is a
term that will probably fall out of
favor now the conservatives have seized
upon it and they'll replace it with some
new woke jargon but
what these scores
mean is that left-wing groups will score
companies on a whole host of progressive
priorities and then the big asset
managers the big institutional investors
that that manage
tens of trillions of dollars worth worth
of money each
they could pull their money out of the
companies and so you say well who cares
who cares if BlackRock or somebody pulls
its money out of a b inbev transcisor
Bush ABN Bev is a big company they're
still selling beer who cares who needs
blackrock's money well what would happen
is the top stock break would would tank
it would show a lack of faith in the
company from the biggest players in the
market
so the company would just go away and so
you've got a handful of major asset
managers BlackRock State Street Vanguard
and others who are really pulling the
strings here and they're not answering
to their customers and they're not
answering to their constituents if it
were a political body like a government
body they're just doing whatever they
want
now why would they do this but another
reason that they would be willing to
kill Bud Light the most popular beer in
America is that Bud Light had not been
growing it had not been explosively
growing it was still the dominant number
one beer in America but some of the
executives felt that it was it was
stagnating and you saw this represented
by Alyssa hershenfeld the VP of
marketing who said we needed to do
something to Jazz up the brand why did
they have to do that well because the
way that modern capitalism works it's
not enough to be the biggest dogs in
town you've got to always be growing if
you're not growing then you're dying and
and and this creates a problem because
there's no there's no limit to it
there's no limit anywhere and so
what this might be is a controlled
demolition of Budweiser because while
ABM Bev transheer Bush might take a hit
in the short run there are so few major
beer distributors that in the long run
it probably won't cost them all that
much money
the number one beer in America now is
Modelo which is hilarious that it's a
Mexican beer that's now the number one
beer in in America and Modelo is not
owned by transheiser Bush in North
America
it's owned by constellation which also
has some work problems too but in the
rest of the world Modelo is owned by
transheja Bush and so there's there
these conglomerates own so much product
and there are so few of them anyway that
they've they've just Consolidated enough
power that okay they lose one of their
lines well they've got a bazillion more
lines to fill it up and the benefit they
get from that is they get to advance the
social policies that they want those
social policies by the way we're down to
even more consolidation and even more
control and even more money and even
more influence for these handful of
oligarchs and so the cost to them
is worth it now
one way to to make sure that you are
protected financially amid all of this
craziness and turmoil and resetting
would be to check out goldens why you
got to check out Birch gold right now
text Knowles to 98 98 98 Congress once
again allowed itself to be pushed into
appeasing the administration and raising
the debt ceiling for the 79th time
Paving the way for continued Reckless
spending and further devaluation of the
dollar as our national debt continues to
Skyrocket how are you protecting your
savings Times Like These are a great
reminder to diversify a portion of your
savings into gold and you can do that
with the help of Birch gold Birch gold
will help you convert an existing Ira or
401K into an IRA in Gold you don't pay a
penny out of pocket when currencies fail
gold is a safe haven how much more time
does the Dollar have protect your
savings with gold Birch gold has an A
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers text
Knowles kwels to 98 98 98 it's your free
info kit on gold text Knowles kwles tune
98 98 98
you might have been one of the tens of
millions of people who watch Netflix's
hit show making a murderer if so then
you are going to love daily wire plus
new exclusive 10 part document series
with Candace Owens convicting a murderer
coming this summer whether it's exposing
BLM or certain fallacies in the
healthcare industry regarding covid
Candace has never been afraid to
challenge the narratives you will find
the truth wherever it leads when Candace
found out that key facts may have been
omitted in Netflix's series she set out
to uncover the real story behind the
notorious Stephen Avery case the end
result is convicting a murder you will
not want to miss it right now there's
never been a better time to become a
daily wire plus member sign up now for
convicting a murderer you will receive
an early bird discount of 25 off your
daily wire Plus Membership you'll also
get all of the other premium content
from daily wire plus including the
greatest lie ever sold what is a woman
and the largest collection of content
from Dr Jordan B Peterson joined now
dailywire.com
subscribe to become a member and see the
truth when it comes out
speaking of BlackRock James O'Keefe
formerly of project Veritas who's now
doing his own thing OMG which is the
O'Keefe Media Group fun little fun
little initialism there uh James has
caught a black rock recruiter
on hidden camera
explaining what BlackRock really is from
the inside
let me tell you it's not three boys
who's controlling the wall
[Music]
and who's that the hedge funds across
the banks
yep you can buy your candidates
obviously we have the system in place
first there's the senator these guys you
got 10 grand you can buy or something I
could give you 500k right now no
questions yeah all right
just like everybody do that does
Blackhawk do that it doesn't matter who
wins
Ukraine is good for business
all right I'll give an example Russia
Russia blows up the grains grains price
of wheat's gonna go mad up Ukrainian
economy is type very largely for wheat
Market Global wheat market prices of
bread and you know literally everything
is it goes up and down this is fantastic
if you're trading
volatility creates opportunity to make
profits
for business
great stuff from James
it's nothing we didn't know
there's nothing surprising in this
undercover video
yes we know people can buy politicians
U.S senators I think cost more than ten
thousand dollars to influence and there
are some politicians who can take the
money and then they won't
take the phone calls and then sometimes
the people who previously backed them
will back their opponents or something I
mean there are some more independent
voices but yeah it's true and very often
what politicians will do in their
defense is they will seek out donors who
share their priorities so that it's not
just that they're being bought off like
a cheap hooker or something like that
it's that they are representing multiple
kinds of constituents they're
representing their Geographic
constituents they're representing
interests that they already support you
know if I I make fun of the the
environmentalist movement that people
who say Global warm is going to kill us
all in five minutes I I mock some of
these new technologies especially the
solar and electric technologies that are
very often just payoffs to Liberal
groups so I'm I'm Pro fossil fuels I'm
pro-oil and natural gas
if I were to run for office
and I I received a campaign donation
from oil and natural gas Industries
I it wouldn't be that they were buying
me off I'm I'm already Pro oil and
natural gas they've never written me any
campaign check but it's a nice alignment
of values and sometimes it's a little
more corrupt than that sometimes it's
just a big corporation that says hey I'm
you know here's the check do what I want
give me the legislation that helps me
okay yeah but we are we already know all
that what about the Ukraine war is good
for business yeah we know that of course
we know that
Dwight Eisenhower warned about that sort
of thing a long time ago can we there's
nothing new here and this this poor
schlub recruiter for BlackRock trying to
impress some girl on a date
doesn't uh doesn't work out well for him
if you are
in a politically I don't know why I'm
giving advice to the libs here if you
are in a politically contentious
important position and some like smoke
and hot chick comes up to you and wants
to go out on a date and then is just
constantly peppering you with questions
about the most controversial aspects of
your job
yeah
it's on you at that point if you answer
okay you are so the power of women
you'll be so blinded by that okay
it's not surprising but
it's disturbing anyway to see it to hear
it oh
the political system doesn't work the
way that we thought it did it's not
about a bill up on Capitol Hill and
three branches and the people
representing this and that and the other
that's no that's not really how the
political order works and one of the
reasons that Trump was very successful
in 2016 and why he might be successful
again is he called that out in a way
that other Republican politicians hadn't
there was an attack on Trump in 2016.
remember the I forget which other
Republican it was probably multiple said
hey Donald you've donated to Democrats
you've written checks to Democrats
that's why you can't be trusted and he
flipped it he said what are you talking
about I've written checks to every
politician I bought all you people off I
did business and I did business in New
York and at an international scale and
so of course I needed to buy you people
often it was easy to buy you off so I
played both sides of the aisle that's
how the system really works so how am I
going to fix the system because I know
it I've played that game a lot meanwhile
you were just the guys that got bought
it was very persuasive when Trump was
able to convince some people who would
be traditionally a little more left-wing
voters to come on over to him it's
because he was talking about a debate
between the the many and the few between
the people and the elites very different
from from what we hear otherwise between
the Republicans and the Democrats and
the left and the right you're saying no
the system is a little different than
you think than it is now speaking of
that political system and how it works
great stuff from Elon Musk
Elon Musk is really impressing me more
and more each day
Elon was responding to someone who said
hey man I'm getting spammed by all these
pro-trans accounts on Twitter that are
calling me CIS and cisgender and Sis Sis
Sis c-i-s and
Elon responded and he said repeated
targeted harassment against any account
will cause the harassing accounts to
receive
at minimum temporary suspensions the
words CIS or cisgender are considered
slurs on this platform now some of you
probably are wondering what CIS means
and I think Norm Macdonald gave the best
explanation I've ever heard of what CIS
means do you know that that you are a
CIS male have you ever heard of that
term
CIS male
c-y-s-m-a-l-a so what it means is that
you are a man you're born a man well as
far as you know as far as I know and you
identify yourself as a man yes that's a
CIS male now I don't understand where is
that is this a new phrase yes it's a way
of marginalizing a normal person
that's all it is
it's a way of marginalizing a normal
person and I saw some self-styled
conservatives
some nominally right-wing people attack
Elon for doing this they would say hey
hey hey hey you we can't do that that's
not total free speech
what's the different what's the
difference between a normal person not
wanting to be called a CIS
but
and a
[Music]
monster
the sooner that we start
distinguishing properly between truth
and falsehood and acting upon those
distinctions that better off we'll be
the sooner that we stop normal
marginalizing normal people the better
off we will
be
now
some some people are a little
trepidatious about this more assertive
new right that has been coming up out of
the ashes of the sort of libertarian
platitudes that took over the rights
sometime in the late 90s and 2000s
there's a more assertive Riot that is
returning to
not even all that much older traditions
on the right which said no we're going
to stand up for a real moral order we're
going to insist upon some standards here
and we're going to say we should have
less of the weird sex stuff and we're
going to talk about virtue and we're
yeah we're going to be confident in our
beliefs we're going to call this a
Christian Nation that that is one nation
under God and and we're going to do that
and I don't want to hear any of your
libertarian claptrap about it because
because by the way even the old school
Libertarians would have agreed with
pretty much all the stuff that the
modern assertive knew
authoritarian conservatives are saying
you know it's just it's not the father
of liberalism John Locke would not have
gone for transgenderism okay Milton
Friedman would not have gotten on board
with all this crazy rainbow stuff or
give me a break all right
give me a break okay so not everyone's
happy about this there is
there was an article that attacked me
yours truly believe it or not
the the article is titled the rights war
on fun
that came after me
which we'll get to in one second
but when you want to hire a really good
employees not like the very misguided
employee who wrote this column for the
nation magazine you got to check out
ZipRecruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles when you want
to hire the best people you've got to
check out ziprecruiter.com Knowles
kw-l-e-s hiring used to be really hard
you would post your job on multiple
sites hope the right people saw it and
then wait for them to apply same goes
for finding a job well you would upload
your resume to every job posting site
then you would comb through never-ending
lists of jobs trying to find the right
position for you zip recruiter is the
best place to find the right position or
if you're an employer the right person
to join your team head on over to
ziprecruiter.com
try it for free ZIP recruiters matching
technology excels at finding the most
qualified candidates for a wide range of
roles if you see a candidate you like
you can easily send them a personal
invitation so they're more likely to
apply it also gives you a Competitive
Edge again other employers who may also
be interested in that candidate their
user-friendly dashboard makes it easy to
filter review and rate your candidates
all from one place four to five and
players who post on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
go to ziprecruiter.com Knowles try
ZipRecruiter for free ziprecruiter.com
recruiter the smartest way
to hire
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Devin Rossi
5966 who says not sure about gynosexual
or gynosexuals that new term that the
libs are pushing for someone who's
attracted to a woman says not sure about
gynosexual but as a man I'm definitely a
no guy sexual
yeah
I'm a sucker for a good pun
it's a good one I might use that so what
is the nation I think this was in the
nation wasn't it this is what here's
what the nation magazine says about
yours truly
and they called me anhedonic you know
opposed to pleasure
they attacked me for pointing out that
demons the most famous representation of
a demon is androgynous trans and opposed
to the complementarity of the Sexes just
likes to Jumble it up okay that's not
main point okay here we go
Knowles is who wrote this
I want to give this person both blame
and credit Chris Lehman
Knowles is perhaps the most dogged
Inquisitor in the new right-wing fatwa
on Pleasure having the same week that
Mike cernovich issued his indictment of
alcohol Knowles took to his podcast to
urge the conservative faithful to build
a bridge to the 13th century and then
the the he goes on to quote this piece
of my show from some days ago where I
said that I don't want America merely to
go back to the days of 2012. I want to
go back to 1220 in western civilization
so anyway
the idea that I
am opposed to pleasure having I think is
proven false by my cigar bill and my bar
bill and my Arts Bill and you know I got
a lot of musical instruments I like to I
don't know I like to have fun for some
people
having a good time is not their idea of
having a good time
for me I like having a good time so that
part I think is ridiculous go I can show
him my my cigar bar bill that's fine
but the second part I really liked
Knowles took to his podcast to urge
conservative faithful to build a bridge
to the 13th century that's what we have
to do we need to build a bridge to the
13th century Bill Clinton in the 90s
said we need to build a bridge to the
21st century we uh didn't work out
we need to build a bridge to the 13th
century and some Libs
think this is crazy
I think this is totally crazy and I
think why and there are even some
squishier conservatives who say oh my
goodness that's crazy back then that was
the Dark Ages
that was terrible the 13th century that
was a terrible time how would you ever
want to go back there and the reason
that people think that is because they
have believed the lies and propaganda
wig history of of liberal Progressive
history which is not based on real
history it's based on uh the flat
self-flattery of the very very modern
people who want to pretend that everyone
who ever came before us was a big dumb
stupid idiot we're the best people that
ever lived and we've done so much better
we're so much smarter we're so much more
virtuous and it just isn't true
in many if not most ways we are much
much stupider we are much less capable
of pleasure
and we are much less skilled and
talented than our forebears who lived in
the 13th century
what are we what do we have in the 13th
century
we had Thomas Aquinas writing the Summa
theologia that's pretty good we were
about to get Dante writing The Divine
Comedy we had the building of beautiful
intricate Cathedrals that lifted men's
eyes not just Rich men's eyes but
especially poor men's eyes up to heaven
we had a lot of Leisure Time
people in the Middle Ages often had more
days off of work than people do today
because there was the liturgical
calendar year there was such a thing as
pilgrimage the and by the way these
great works of art they weren't just
locked away in a handful of museums and
Cosmopolitan cities that people would go
to this great beautiful art was
throughout the culture
and people would regularly get to
experience this stuff they had a sense
of purpose in their lives they were
nearer to family they were not suffering
from the spiking rates of depression
that plague not the medieval people not
the ancient people the modern people are
the ones who are suffering from that
they had children and They carried on
their civilization unlike the modern
people who were choosing not to do that
at all
it's it's a historical
and it's it's
perfect though I mean it it tells you
everything you need to know about our
era that people today who don't know a
damn thing who could who couldn't
probably tell you even what Thomas
Aquinas or his predecessors or Aristotle
or any serious philosopher we're even
talking about
modern people for whom the the heights
of satisfaction involve playing some
video games and eating brunch and
looking at porn modern people are going
to lecture the medievals and the
Scholastics on a serious good
flourishing life it's just such a joke
but of course it's the case that those
modern people
[Music]
would also fall into the the chief the
highest of the of the seven deadly sins
and that's Pride
which we're celebrating right now we're
in the middle of pride month we think oh
yeah this culture that we're in where we
don't really build anything beautiful
anymore and all the art and architecture
is just absolutely hideous and degrading
and we we've now we're now turning a
generation of young people into
voluntary prostitutes on the internet
and arousing everyone's lusts and
gluttony and and chopping up our body
parts and just not having any kids and
not being near our families and not yeah
yeah oh yeah it's awesome and great
we're so much better
everyone who came before us was just
crazy because they didn't have like
electric toothbrushes or something so
yeah okay I don't want to go back to
13th century Dentistry but in most other
Realms of life I think it would be
probably pretty good to return return
with a V return to tradition
speaking of banning stuff
just sort of we've got a little bit of
time I'll get into this the good old
Italians who are a fairly traditional
people even after the rise of the modern
secular Italian nation state which was
had all sorts of attacks on the church
and you know that country hasn't really
been able to govern itself properly
since Octavian well Italy there's a deep
kind of conservatism to the Italians and
they're expressing this now Italian
lawmakers have begun to debate
a proposal to criminalize surrogacy
arranged abroad it's already illegal in
Italy but they want to criminalize it
even if it's done abroad this is under
prime minister Georgia Maloney's ruling
coalition
couples found guilty of trying to have
children through surrogates living
overseas face three months to two years
in prison a fine of six hundred thousand
Euro to one million euro under the draft
bill which was submitted by a woman
Carolina varkey who's a member of the
conservative party the the brothers of
Italy
great great stuff and the libs are
whining about it here's what the lips
are saying they're saying there are no
countries in which surrogacy is
prosecuted if done legally abroad
Italy's proposal is a unique first this
is an Alexander Schuster who's a
pro-lgbt LMNOP lawyer says there
are instances in which crimes are
persecuted also if done abroad but this
is usually only for Universal crimes
like pedophilia or crimes against a
state or sexual tourism I think
that
uh creating a child in a test tube with
the express purpose of denying that
child potentially a natural mother or
potentially a natural father or uh for
purchasing that child effectively or for
depriving that child of the right to to
be conceived as a product of the
conjugal act between his parents who are
who are married for life I think that's
a universal crime too
I think that's that's quite a universal
crime actually at least as much as
sexual tourism it is sexual tourism
it's a very deep kind of sexual tourism
and I don't want to be too harsh on
people who have engaged in surrogacy
because it's a relatively new technology
and people are trying it out and there
are
normal married couples who are trying it
out and there are homosexuals who are
trying it out and there are single
people trying they're they're just rich
people who don't want their body to
undergo the trauma of of being pregnant
giving birth so they just pay some poor
woman to do it for them
and I get it it's a new thing and
I think a lot of people
haven't really thought through this and
now we're beginning to think through
this and we're having a debate over it
we're beginning to see that the process
is just ghastly
and it should not be permitted obviously
and it doesn't mean that children who
have been conceived through surrogacy
are evil or bad or that it's bad that
they exist
they can be a good end you know God
turns all sorts of evil toward good ends
but good ends do not justify our evil
means ever our immoral means we can't do
it and so
this is absolutely great stuff coming
out of Italy the United States should
take up a similar law we should just ban
this this is deeply disordered there are
all sorts of problems that come from it
it is immoral for every person involved
and this is a very proper use of the
state the the fathers of liberalism I
promise you even John Locke even the the
libertarian Heroes
they would not have gotten behind this
kind of thing maybe some of the craziest
ones would have but but most of them
would not have gotten behind this sort
of thing
and the fact that today the so-called
conservatives might be
might be giving this quarter is
absolutely insane
it's not authoritarian just to to wield
just political power to stop evil evil
things from happening that's just called
just Authority that's just the point of
government okay
I'm sorry to say there's no member block
today because I'm on the road
and
producer Jacob won't hand me that iPad
and we've listen we've talked about it
we're probably going to talk about it a
little bit more
afterward but for now November black so
I will see you all
tomorrow I'm Michael Knowles this the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
foreign